we have a new front runner it feels
really good the death of a thousand
birds and the worst pool party ever very
much confused more confusing ever this
is your bachelor season 24 episode 3
recap grab your glasses it's time for
roses and roses a hey everybody it's me
Lauren Xena guys I had to be standing to
properly show of this dress as you know
we are only doing chic in 2020 I told
you that last week and look at this
turtleneck look at these long sleeves
look at these pockets you know I love a
dress with pockets and it's so playful
and gives me so many vibes and it just
won't be as good or when I sit down so
we wanted to give it its moment in the
spotlight now much like how many of
these women are being sent home and
we'll never know them I want you to know
this dress though and it has so many
vibes very fluid in the curve and Harry
Potter
Accio detail beautiful light your little
plane over here
PTL very handmade sale in Handmaid's
Tale if the women were being sent only
go to the colonies and see now I'm
sitting and it's not as chic but it's
fine it's fine we can't be perfect
Aleya I've held several titles I'm so
used to be yes another new feature for
2020 and we couldn't be more on brand I
mean putting our logo on a wine glass
okay
[Applause]
do you guys watch Handmaid's Tale it is
such an intense show you never know
what's gonna happen but you know what's
gonna be bad and that's how I felt
throughout the entire episode this week
so ominous
so dark so tearful not cheerful we're
missing a bit of that playfulness aren't
we I think that's why Demi Burnett was
brought back this week to bring a little
pop to bring a little fun to bring a
little bit of that Demi do-right you
know a little joy hey guys it's me in my
office wearing sunglasses because to be
honest I'm still emotionally recovering
from Brad and Jen at the SAG Awards did
you guys see that I think you did
because you love a show about love and
that was love I mean I was deeply shook
at the right the two of them touching
raising so many questions wondering are
they just giving fans a moment of
reconciliation that we've all longed to
see for so many years or is there
something more a year a lingering
chemistry should Jennifer give Brad and
move forward and be with him after
everything that he put it through so
publicly and is she just over him
entirely she's been married and divorced
since everything with the two of them I
was really thinking about it and
honestly not even sure if I would have
the energy to do the bachelor this week
but turns out yes always in forever
right let's get to it we open on the
aftermath of the champagne full battle
of the bullies and everyone's looking a
little worse for the wear aren't they
nobody's looking great I'm sorry it's
the morning after and everyone's still
crying
has he been crying through the night so
I'm singing a little laughter a little
joy the sun's not even out you know and
that's hard it's hard I'm affected by
the seasons then
yeah citizens were going through a lot
let's start off strong a drink every
time that Hanna an says she's not a
champagne stealer
why would I steal champagne never she
had paint stealer cuz I would not steal
[ __ ] up hey I'm not a champagne stealer
what thing to declare I thought it was
interesting that she didn't say I'm not
a thief she said quite specifically I'm
not a champagne steel I would not steal
your champagne look I don't know did
everybody have a shoplifting moment as a
child I actually didn't I was too afraid
of my mom not the law my mother you just
don't know what's gonna happen I gotta
give another shout-out to my girl in the
Tosha who made so many great points last
episode this week she's coming in hot
landed safely with the one-liner of the
week she says you just never know you
never know when someone is gonna snap
snap crackle crackle or pop snap crackle
guys would you buy this glass let me
know in the comments below
oh this dress is just so just a lot now
you know who was popping this episode
Victoria Pease she says she got a date
card last night and getting a date card
I was so excited about going on a date
today and I wrote down did I miss that I
don't know when that happened but she's
going on a date and her hair looks good
so great
Peter picks her up and he is driving a
cute little red truck for no apparent
reason they always want to give them a
fun car and that truck is really holding
up traffic isn't it drink for every car
that's like hey Baxter can you drive
what's your biggest driving pet peeve I
hate when people don't use their signals
you know because it's the easiest thing
in the world to just flick your signal
I'm just up and down and there you go
and now you're communicating with your
fellow drivers out on the road and
keeping everyone a little bit safer life
is about communication I think I'm gonna
where you already have a relationship
got to be able to interact with where
there's driving on the road are walking
on the road or something that you're
dating sleeping with marrying whatever
use your signals this is my favorite
Peter and Victoria are communicating
they're having important discussions
like do you like red wine better or
white that is such a critical decision
to make I was deeply offended to be
honest that Rosie didn't come up as part
of the options I felt so good just it
soak in every single moment that I have
with just him
Victoria Pete really endeared me to her
she talked about how she didn't think
that she was worthy of a man like Peter
I never thought that could be the kind
of man
I would be happy and I just wanted to
tell her girl you are girl you aren't
valid you are driven you are intelligent
you are confidence you are caring you
are beautiful you are important I wanted
to take a moment to blog because I also
keep thinking about Victoria P we're
getting to know the ladies better now
and we saw so much a Victoria this
weekend look I don't know what happens
with her and Peter but if Victoria P is
single Victoria P for Bachelorette what
do you guys think she has such a deep
emotional story she seems quite mature
she's honest about her feelings she's
beautiful I like her let me know in the
comments below we're getting to know the
women a bit better now so if you have
other thoughts for Bachelorette
do tell pray for brettandjen okay so my
friends I would love to lion dance now
well I like Victoria P but I'm not sure
about the D and the t is for dancing
guys they're dancing again we have so
far danced in every episode of this
season we got the counter counter maybe
now we need the two-step tally
oh okay yeah Peter didn't dance with
Hannah I don't know when this happened
god this dress sitting down it's like
the pockets have become birthing hips I
don't know there's a lot they like have
their new country outfits and they're so
color-coordinated and Peter says he
loves lion dancing peter has so many
layers you know we know he's German you
know he's Cuban we know he's Californian
and now we know he's a country boy I
guess I don't know so deep such an onion
always discovering new things you know
we might start a first class walk our
way back with your premium economy
continue it on down to regular economy
and who knows what's at the back of the
plane in that bathroom where you can
stand in line and wait as opposed to the
front we're running low on plane
metaphors aren't we now while they're
dancing back at the mansion people are
discussing you guys want to talk yeah
okay yeah Hannah Anne and Kelsey are
having it out I like this you guys
they're gonna discuss things after
champagne gate it's gonna be positive
it's gonna be productive it's gonna be
powerful talk it out the word bully
that's a very serious accusation to make
and it's devolving pretty quickly
they're agreeing to disagree we can
agree to disagree on that which is okay
but it's not the best resolution is it I
apologize for that but and then Kelsey's
giving an apology but it's got a butt
attached to it but you you you told me
to say it away from you and that's not
great so we're gonna make this about me
no Hannah Ann is making some good points
like Kelsey's saying that she doesn't
know where I don't know you and Hannah's
saying well ya know why did you call me
fake you don't know me so why don't you
don't I'm not goin around
and now Hana and is crying at Kelsey's
saying she doesn't even like champagne I
don't even really like champagne what I
really like champagne what why'd you do
this that after the finesse Co of the
champagne and just say Finn asked oh the
fanaa stealing it's a fiasco that's what
all this is the ask Oh hmm what I was
tired of all the drama yeah this could
have gone better
perfect but what is going well as Peters
date with Victoria Pete she tells her
story in a mime I did I'd passed away
when I was really not and she's been
there's so much you know I'm sitting
here thinking we've got these
frontrunners in Hannah and and Matt a
son but Peter seems to be falling for
Victoria now he tells her he has never
been so inspired by a person I have
never been inspired by someone so much
of my entire life and that it feels
quote so insanely right with her it
feels so right
Wow Peter think insanely right I mean
this is no propeller plane-- of a
statement you know what I'm saying this
is a 747 sentence it's big it's a 747
big but okay thanks but back to the
mansion where things aren't so serious
how do we know they're not so serious
because everybody seems to be drinking
and one woman is engaging in some pilot
cosplay
Peter yes that's God is it a liya alia
Alia oh yeah I have spelled her name no
less than seven different ways on this
piece of paper okay well she's there and
Aleya reveals she is a former pageant
girl basically everybody like see of me
and think because of pageants and what I
do that I'm like the sweet little
elegant proper thing and did she say she
can get nasty
bro I asked she definitely said she can
put on a face when she needs to know I'm
like very good at putting on face and I
need to what does that mean I don't know
very ominous
don't drink for every ominous statement
this episode do you mind if i kidnap you
if i don't answer a question how to
answer without answering like those
things are easy for ya if you're doing
this for any other reason besides seeing
if this can work with me I do not have
time for that so again we needed to keep
things lighter and Demi Burnett is back
to help with a group date and they're
about to Rocky's girls world she comes
in and wakes the women up by whacking
them with pillows
[Music]
got don't drink for every rough morning
this episode it's another tough mmm
difficult looks you know I wouldn't want
anybody filming me when I first wake up
in the morning but it was interesting to
see where the women's sleep wasn't it in
those bunk beds why don't you guys think
of their rooms you can understand right
how this is set up for drama to be
created those are close quarters this is
like camp
look I'm not someone who can't share a
room like I need to be like here's my
space and my stuffs in it and this is my
corner where my items are okay and it
means you're not come in here do you
know what I'm saying their stuff is all
over the meager little hallways that
they have only on this show do you stay
in a mansion but you're sleeping in a
bunk bed and your items are just piled
upon the floor very not chic you know
very not 2020 for me personally so the
women get outfits because they're gonna
be on a pillow fight dating
and did Keanu call lingerie linger II
like a cute pajama Ling reset yeah she
did she did do it didn't she
yeah drink for every mispronounce common
word in this episode after the finish go
of the champagne steel against the
pajama lingers you guys want to get
these glasses it's just a good marker
for you the sticker up here
that's your fill line so you just keep
going because you gotta make sure drink
for every time we're in a country bar
saloon in this episode we are at a
freaking saloon why why so we're having
a pillow fight in a bar and don't drink
for every feather you see
[Music]
I just giving you out all the birds make
your birds four down girls hope they
don't just pluck them I don't know do
they Sam you look confused and scared
are the birds dead
did they kill the birds they kill the
birds can we google it so they kill the
birds
she's googling it just find out if they
kill the birds do you think humanely
pluck the birds or the births dead
[ __ ] okay not killing do you guys use
down pillows they're kind of a down
alternative let me know in the comments
below this is so heavy
Wow
thank you guys so much for all the love
and comments on the last episode I
really needed that it's not a lot of
breathing in this dress again I've been
trying to be chic but it turns out
everything chic doesn't breathe
breathing isn't chic the pillow fight
got aggressive didn't it don't drink for
every power pillow smack
Aleya beats Sydney literally beats her
down she beats her in the pillow fight
because the layest says everyone thinks
I'm a pageant person everybody and I
want to prove that I'm not and I'm like
who who thinks you're a pageant person
we don't even know you yeah I don't know
and then drink for every ominous comment
in this episode Sydney makes these
promises about what she's gonna do to
Alea she'll get a rude awakening sooner
or later in this voice that is so
incredibly even but it is deeply
unsettling to me she is saying that Alea
doesn't see what's coming for her that
the pain is going to be so unimaginable
that she wouldn't wish it upon her worst
enemies worst enemies the deepest
darkest realms of the sad horrible help
it's of the universe
yeah but Alea will not be stopped
Alea is a pageant girl alia knows how to
put on different faces she said it
herself
and so we see her have this pretty good
conversation with Peter she really
opened up this is like too heavy now
okay Jesus oh my god I can't drink a
whole bottle I've never done this
now that's a [ __ ] light mm-hmm and we
see Sydney's mission unfold Sydney is on
a fact-finding mission do you like work
at all I have three job
and when I say fact-finding mission I
mean that Sydney is looking for Alea to
make some admissions about who she is as
a person so that Sydney can use them
against her later
you sound so rehearsed so like on you
know what I mean and if cameras you're
just like on it's a dark episode guys
you know it's like it's like here's our
plane is it gonna land or I say got it
oh these spin that's fun and it now
if you come in here worrying about how
you're perceived then you're not gonna
be your real self to Peter and like
that's what he's here to find it's like
a real person I have to say I was a
little bit worried about Sydney here I
think it's always a bad idea when any
contestant on these shows focuses on
someone else focus on yourself I want to
just kind of squash this now Sydney has
told him that she thinks some of the
women in the house are they just so
artificial and I could not believe this
were you guys surprised Peter not only
had no problem with what Sydney was
saying but he wanted to lay out what she
was saying in front of everybody
including a layeth we're some concerns
in regards to just some people here
possibly not being real with me so she
then had to address it Sydney you had
mentioned that there were people that
maybe are different off-camera
or different in the house when I'm not
there let me know whose side you were on
here
I'll be honest it all felt messy I
didn't think that a laya should have
gone to Peter think that it's personally
you think would have been fake just
and I didn't think that Peter should
have gone to everyone Olea kind of has
to address everything and Peter chooses
Sydney's side he even gives her the rose
I was blown away
Why What who gets a rose when they
titled this is unprecedented is the show
changing I don't Oh
this dress is tight I can't move in it
so what do you guys think he gave her
the rose and I had to ask myself the
deep emotional question of the week
which was what are we rewarding here
really and then we're back at the
mansion for a pool party and Peter seems
into Sydney another new frontrunner
emerging this episode thank you for for
being so strong I'm getting some of that
I can lean on because he even takes the
time to pull send me aside and apologize
to her for calling out their
conversation in front of everyone I
I felt horrible a bit about you in that
position okay
and they share a quick kiss and I'll be
honest they seem a bit into each other
I'm not ever going to apologize for
doing or saying their pain anything now
Alea is standing firm on her ground she
says that no one has an issue with her
personality nobody else has nobody's
even like you did but drink every time
someone says they have an issue with her
personality she like backs a certain way
from the camera when the cameras on yes
big name was not wrong in her
speculation of alia all of a sudden the
cameras come on and like her voice goes
up like five octaves but Olea aside we
always get a little moment with matp
don't we yes Peter tells Maddie that
they went on the best first date he's
ever had greatest first date ever
oh that's another 747 from Peter
[Music]
so P for Peter is confused and who will
he turn to Victoria PE it's P for the
person he can trust so he brings her
into the forest to get our opinion about
Alea god I love all of this forest work
with Peter and Victoria P here they are
throw more trees here's another shot so
much forest oh now they're holding hands
in the forest coming into this she was
really open to all the opportunities
that will come after this and drink
every time we find out that a cast
member is also a pageant queen I was
like Miss Louise Yunnan well bad habit
of conscience
and the Victoria P and the lay on knew
each other beforehand Victoria P says
the Millea told her that she could not
tell the producers that they knew each
other you know that she asked that I not
tell producers bad we knew one another
why why right
Peter Webber was in love with Hannah
Brown a pageant queen from Alabama and
two of his frontrunners at least or
knowledge Madison and Sydney are both
from Alabama a variety of his front
runners are pageant queens and so he's
got one front runner named Hannah Wow
anyway Victoria piece says that Alea had
discussed with her potential
opportunities that she would get out of
being on the show even if she didn't
wind up with Peter and there is
certainly a judgment here and a question
about whether someone is here for the
right reasons she was really open to all
the opportunities that will come after
this but how do you guys feel about this
I don't have a problem with people
talking about what they might get out of
going on the show at the end of the day
you're going on a reality TV show
whether you're the lead or the
contestant whatever you know that being
on the show is gonna get you Instagram
followers potential jobs that's just a
given and I don't think that's anything
new so to be honest I don't judge it
sorry we talk again okay you know I
thought this was a pool party have we
even seen the pool everyone's in
swimsuits but they seem like they're
cold and crying it's the worst pool
party I don't like pool parties I was so
pale anyway he's gone home alright so
Peter has left and McKenna is frustrated
so
and I don't blame her
and he's back in a gray suit he's
looking good
okay Kelsey and Kelsey got a rose and
then Hannah and got a rose you know what
it was kind of nice to see them get
roses back to back and you guys I know
that they had their issues but I think
they mended fences because I did see
Hanna and give a very nice comment on
Kelsey's Instagram and you know what
that's about growth and I love it ladies
sorry for the interruption but there's
been a little bit of a change tonight so
it comes down to one final rose and
McKenna is worried that she's not going
to get a rose but I was thinking McKenna
girl you're fine he made out with you on
a counter you know I realized quickly
about Peter that there are two telltale
signs that he cares about a person he
makes out with you on a countertop and
he refers to you by two names Hannah
brown
countertop two names McKenna countertop
Hannah and two names whatever you see
I'm saying anyway
and Peter sends Alejo home
I found this rather shocking did you
guys think this was fair kind of felt
like Alea was getting Lampoon or she
hadn't even really done anything that
wrong let me know the comments below and
Peter seemed to regret it too as he was
talking to these producers it was the
last ominous comment of the night
because as we saw in the trailer Alea
will return
shut the front do I got to tell you guys
though all this back and forth is not
chic and as we've discussed 20/20 is the
heir of chic only so can we keep it
shake Bader can't wait keep it shake and
oh wow you know what else is not shape
we also see in the trailer that Victoria
F is getting a one-on-one date with
Peter where they will see a performance
by some country singer named chase rice
or something
bottom line Victoria says that she dated
chase that saw court this shows really
the gift that keeps on giving I credit
the producers okay not chic but sure is
good TV I love you guys so much thank
you for watching I adore you please
leave your comments below you can find
me on cameo also on the instagrams and
the Twitter's in honor of this week's
episode I will leave you all with an
incredibly ominous statement said in a
definitively monotone tone the higher
you fly the harder you fall
bye
[Music]
you